when we were getting to know you guys to
decide like do we want to do this do we
want to actually partner with you guys
and and do a deal together
um we would ask you a bunch of questions
like at dinners or at the bar or
whatever and
your guys's stories and answers were so
entertaining that I was like
dude these guys need to come on the
podcast if they I was like if I had just
recorded this dinner
this would have been like one of the
best podcast episodes we've ever done
probably the best
laughs
what's up y'all Sean here uh this is a
special episode my company the milk Road
just got acquired so the news is out and
um I can finally talk about it I've been
kind of hinting at it on the podcast for
those who are listening and um yeah if
the news is out and this episode is me
and the dudes who bought it so you're
gonna meet these guys and you're gonna
see who why would I sell right like we
started this thing it grew like crazy it
was profitable like the thing was
working so why so and I talked a little
bit about that but the biggest reason
honestly was
these guys uh these are people that I
wanted to be able to work with and get
to know better and they're people that I
thought if I give them
you know this company and I own I still
own a minority stake in it that Minority
stake in five years is going to be worth
a lot because I believe in these guys
and what they've done they've done it
before they've built and sold companies
worth you know over a hundreds million
hundreds of millions of dollars and I
think they're going to do it again here
um this the episode is a little funny it
starts off a little slow uh but then
around 15 minutes in we're done talking
about the acquisition and I'm frankly
I'm done talking a little bit and I let
these guys shine and they tell stories
about you know how their early projects
like how they you know all the different
projects they worked on some that failed
spectacularly and some that succeeded
um you know their philosophy around
business and negotiations and stuff like
that it gets really good after that so
definitely stick through if you like
this podcast like if you like my first
million you will like these guys uh I'm
gonna just I'll build the characters you
got Mike who is this like
Workhorse so anybody who likes you know
a grinder somebody who's Scrappy
somebody who can bounce back from defeat
he tells a ton of stories about like
basically getting his ass kicked almost
failing and then somehow pulling it off
um so Mike is this Workhorse of a guy
I've gotten to see him in action with
the milk Road this guy is like lives in
the details and in the weeds it's
amazing uh and then Kendall is the
opposite he's like how can I work
smarter not harder he's the Mr shortcut
he is the guy who finds a way
um to make something happen right like
you know he yeah he's the guy who hacked
the Tesla referral program and ended up
getting multiple Tesla roadsters and
he's the guy who did the same thing with
Uber and Lyft and as like you know Uber
credits for life and Lyft credits for
like he's just a guy who's gonna solve
the puzzle and uh and get the shortcut
solution he will find the clever the
clever way to get it done so these two
guys are awesome and um I think you guys
you guys really like him so enjoy this
episode
um all right so we should we should do
this so
welcome to the show I've been telling
you guys you got to come on uh for a
couple months now and I'm glad we're
doing this so we will I think we should
frame this in a couple ways we got
together because you guys just bought my
company you bought the milk Road and so
we're gonna talk about that we're gonna
talk about
how that happened how that went down why
you guys decided to do it good stuff
like that then we're going to talk a
little bit about
you know what's the plan but really the
thing I thought would be
the best out of this conversation my
sort of secret plan was when we were
getting to know you guys to decide like
do we want to do this do we want to
actually partner with you guys and and
do a deal together
um we would ask you a bunch of questions
like at dinners or at the bar or
whatever and
your guys's stories and answers were so
entertaining that I was like
dude these guys need to come on the
podcast if they I was like if I had just
recorded this dinner
this would have been like one of the
best podcast episodes we've ever done
probably probably the best and so then I
was like all right
my job here is to somehow recreate that
dinner because actually there's a lot of
pressure I know
how good this episode could be if I do
my job and uh usually with a guest you
know hey you just show up they do
whatever they're gonna do but in this
case I've heard the stories myself so I
gotta find a way to to recreate that so
that's my challenge you guys it should
be easy it's you know
um just you're gonna tell your stories
and I think at the end of this people
will know a little bit about what
happened with the milk road but also a
lot about you guys because I became a
fan of you during the process of doing
the deal and I think a lot of other
people are going to become fancy you
guys too during this because you guys
are pretty low-keyed why is that why are
you guys like so under the radar and I
asked this as a guy who's like I'm
constantly on the stage being like look
at me you know I'm great and then I meet
people who are really really great and
they're not trying to do that so what's
the is it
don't have time is it Shy what's the
reason that you don't do that let's
start with you I think it's probably shy
and it's just something that I never
thought I needed to do
and then when I met you I'm like I'm
doing everything all wrong but we had a
hilarious day where I don't know how
this happened
in San Francisco where I usually don't
put the joke on the pot is I don't leave
my house but when I do leave my house uh
once in a while get bumped into and be
like oh hey love the Pod for some reason
that day something was going my way and
like I don't know like six or seven
people stopped us in a row and you guys
must have been like what the hell's
going almost your reaction to that I was
like did you plan this I could not
believe how many people were coming up
to you and you know I'm a big fan of the
Pod I'm doing this project I did a MFM
search engine like it was insane yeah
that was pretty crazy yeah the guy from
the hospital he's like I just came from
the hospital looking for Sean that was a
little I don't know what that means I
was like do you have security cameras
because he said he goes I just came from
the hospital and then
we're like oh okay yeah and then later
somebody was like why did he come from
the hospital like did anybody catch that
and we had no explanation uh because he
had like a you know like the patient has
escaped you know sticker on it on his
shirt basically yeah
um but I'm glad you guys are doing it uh
so let's start with the milk run people
want to know uh you know the news just
came out today this pod will come out
right after that
um we sold it and people want to know
how that went down I could tell it from
my perspective but maybe I don't know
let's do it from your perspective how
did how did this all happen yeah for
sure so Carter who is our finance was a
big fan and he shared it with us Mike
and I and we subscribed to it and every
time we'd open it we're like uh they're
doing it so well they're just a while
back or this is six months ago okay and
you know every time we read it we we
talked about it we talked about the
memes how funny it was but also how
informative it was and that's kind of
what we were trying to do with bitfo is
just like make the best content and
actually have people read it I feel like
you know you could have the 10 000 words
but that doesn't mean much to people
it's like how do we get that 750 uh
words that really punches and I feel
like that's what you guys have done and
uh you know it came to a point where I'm
like we should talk to these guys but at
that point we hadn't yeah and I think we
reached out to you guys I remember
having a conversation with Ben about
growth and it was like Ben you know
those like sites that are just like I
don't know what's the price of Bitcoin
what's the price of ethereum I was like
what if we just go on there and like I
don't know go I don't know I was like I
wrote I was like it's probably just like
some 19 year old kid like just offer
them like a dollar for every email
subscriber let's just see if they'll put
it up put our ad up and I think that's
how we reached out alrighty got in touch
with one of you guys about that Ben
reached out to I don't even know who
somebody got back to us and you know it
wasn't something we were going to do we
were it was like offering a dollar per
sub or whatever it turns out you weren't
a kid yeah you're actually 32 we weren't
17. um but we just wanted to meet you
guys so we're like let's take the
meeting and uh yeah about 10 minutes
into that we were messaging on the side
it's like we got to buy this thing we've
got to figure out a way the funny thing
is I don't know if I told you this but
that same day uh like we had just been
full force working on milk Road this is
the best it's gonna be awesome dude
we're just every day and like I'm a big
like pat on the back self pad on the
back kind of guy every day I'd basically
tell Ben this is amazing we've launched
this thing and only in this many months
we've already grown this fast it's gonna
be so good this many years in but you
know it's gonna be great and then one
day I just hit Ben with a curveball in
slack and this is the same day I go
I go how much would you sell this for
right now and uh he's like what like I
don't know do you want to sell it I was
like that's not what I said I said how
much would you sell it for right now
he's like oh maybe this number and I was
like yeah I think my number's like you
know that plus one and he was like
I know he was like okay
um what do you do with that I was like
let's see if we could sell it and I was
like I'm very impulsive like that like I
was wake up one day that's how I got my
dog I just woke up one day and I just
hey get in the car we're gonna go let's
go find a dog and we were like
craigslisting in the car to find dogs
and we've got a dog that day and that's
kind of what happened with this and so
literally he calls me like later that
afternoon he's like
dude so weird I just talked to these
guys and they mentioned on the call if
you'd ever be interested blah blah and I
was like ah well who are they I you know
I've never heard of these guys and he's
like no they're legit and I was like
what he's like yeah I Googled him and
whatever and like he's like one of them
built like the largest I don't know how
you describe it like the largest gold
website yeah gold e-commerce precious
metals e-commerce precious metal
e-commerce site so basically JM Bullion
is the name of it if you want to go buy
sell gold silver whatever you can go do
it there and I knew that name because my
brother-in-law buys from Champions right
so he's so he had been telling me you
know as he's like stashing away little
like coins in his safe and I'm like all
right good for you man
um screw up his orders yeah yeah he gets
it every time and he's like you know
whatever he's hoarding gold so
you guys you built that that was a
couple hundred million dollar company
and then you had done the same thing in
the sports betting side same thing like
roughly 100 million dollars worth of
exits and I was like oh these guys are
actually super legit okay uh scratch the
whole 19 year old kid offer him a dollar
let's see what we can get these guys to
offer us and then that's sort of how the
deal
uh evolve from there and so
so that's like how we met then actually
making a deal uh somebody said this the
other day they go the rule of they call
it the rule of five they go and any deal
it's gonna follow what fall apart five
times if it's gonna get if it's gonna
get done it's gonna fall apart five
times and I think we kind of did that
though we did every three or four times
at least
um along the way I do have a question
about it which is
not just how it all happened but of
course I've been wanted to ask and I get
to put you guys on the spot here
how could we have negotiated better so I
asked Ben I go what can we ask these
guys on the Pod he goes because you ask
him about the deal negotiation I go yeah
I should ask him could we have gotten
more because that was the my first
acquisition that was the question I
asked uh the CEO and he was like you
couldn't have got a dollar more and I
was like that feels good but it feels
like a lie it's never actually the case
so from your guy's perspective how did
we negotiate give us a grade and uh tell
us how we did I would say it was uh A
minus
I was gonna say a b okay yeah I mean I
mean I would give everyone almost a b
around you know the table I feel like
each one of us at one point kind of were
like ah this isn't gonna work and it
wasn't as kind of straightforward as
you'd like a deal but as you said both
my deals every time I was like it's not
gonna work you know for one reason or
another you get to the point of they're
over here I'm over here and we're not
getting anywhere close right
and then you know you figure it out or
you walk away and you know we had those
walkaways uh with you I think twice yeah
I think you guys did it one time and we
did it another time yeah yeah I said a
minus because at the end like when we
made that final you know the last little
chunk yeah we were that was it for us we
just said we're walking if this doesn't
work
um we talked about this last night I
think one thing that would have helped a
lot so he has a non-compete on gambling
as we talked about and you know one of
the times it fell apart was we Scott's
into the diligence after we'd already
agreed on a number and there was found
out I was a degenerator
there's a little more gambling a
gambling sponsor Revenue there than we
thought and I think that if that had
come out a lot earlier you guys probably
could have guided us better to like hey
well for next month we're going to
Target this stuff yeah yeah we didn't
know that was a problem because it's not
in front we don't have a non-compete so
yeah this is great
um yeah that's all right that's that's
good we did talk about it at dinner you
did yeah we would have met you yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah at that dinner yeah
um all right so let's talk about you
know how this deal kind of evolves why
do you buy a business like this what's
the what's the thinking what's the
rationale and
you guys have been on the seller side
you've sold your businesses what's the
difference in in the mentality there
Mike you want to take this one yeah so
you know reason we bought you guys we
felt like everything we were doing was
just gonna work a lot better on their
brand and so like the SEO play which is
our thing you know we're building these
content driven sites that we want to
rank in Google for you know money terms
and crypto like buy Bitcoin blend
Bitcoin all those sorts of things yeah
we should explain your guys's magic your
superpower your superpower is somebody
goes to Google and they say
Buy Gold Online the best place to buy
gold best place to
um you know bet you know on whatever
and your guys's whole career basically
is ranked number one for that and you
did it with the sports betting and the
gold but before that you did it with
poker before that you did it with other
stuff and like we'll go into some of
those funny funny stories in a second
um but that's your guys's secret sauce
to which I was like why do they need a
newsletter the newsletter doesn't do
that that doesn't that's not the answer
but there is some I don't know Synergy
there for you yeah so it's you know just
this brand component of like Google has
really moved towards rewarding brands
that users are actually going to be
going searching for like milk road is
being searched hundreds of times a day
and that's such an indicator to Google
of like humans are interested in this
brand same with JM James getting
thousands of searches a day for JM
Bullion so like when we were building
our sites like defy rate.com was the one
that we merged into milk Road no one's
out there really looking for this site
you know we're just trying to figure out
how to get it up in Google So eventually
it will become a brand so for us it was
like hey we get to jump forward you know
a year in this journey if we buy this
newsletter by the website roll it in and
then you know reap these benefits
forevermore you're going to continue to
get really amazing backlinks because you
do all these awesome interviews
um it was you know that was my my piece
and I think too it was really
complimentary you know like the
newsletter content could go on the
website you know we'd be able to be in
the inbox of of our users along with hey
you know there's a different segment of
our users that are going to go to our
website and so you know those type of uh
ways to you know Reach people are like
really exciting for us and so that was
kind of like all right they have the
brand they have a voice and you know
they have uh you know a really
complementary uh
you know
and it was working during the bear
Market yeah that's the biggest our
business was still growing and
generating revenue and profit during the
crypto winter which is hard for because
if you're not like you know what
bitcoin's price goes down there's a lot
less people searching how do I buy
Bitcoin right now you know and so uh or
like you know D5 implodes or whatever
well then people aren't looking to
borrow or land at the same rates uh so I
think that also helps because there's
like oh this is a business that will
work even in the winters yeah and you
had Diversified advertisers they're not
all crypto companies so yeah we're like
yeah this can work even if crypto's dead
for a while and so the question on our
side was do we want to sell right why
sell do we want to sell and I think you
know there's
probably a three-pronged answer to that
the answer is
first uh
a lot of decisions just get made through
like who your nature your personality
and I've gotten to know my nature a
little bit over the last few years and
it is very much a I'm good at starting
things I'm good at finding the the
something from nothing
but taking the something and just
fine-tuning it day after day making it
better which is where most of the values
created in business is uh not something
that I just get super excited about and
so that was always hard for me because
I could create something get it off the
ground get it to work and then as it
worked my interest would fade and you
know so that was like a personal thing I
was I sort of knew that so I said if if
I'm getting a good deal now
but I know it'd be better if I held it
for four years great but am I Really
Gonna have this same energy I have today
four years from now I can't know that
that's true for me as a operator whereas
about you guys and I'll go into why I
thought you guys would be much better
owners of the business was
you're like that Mike is a absolute
animal Workhorse I actually uh like
we've been working together a little bit
now and I see your level of detail
attention to detail is crazy like you
are looking at this email you know like
in the morning in the afternoon in the
evening then the feedback and then do it
again the next day I love it I was like
wow this guy is this guy's an animal
um and I thought okay maybe he's just
doing at the beginning no that's just
kind of who you are yeah I mean that was
you know with JM same thing like myself
and the the other partner who I ran that
with we were probably like the biggest
readers of the gold and silver stuff
Reddit like on the planet because we
just wanted to ingest all this what are
the people thinking you know and that's
really we got so many wins just
observing that implementing those things
so I asked you guys some questions
before the Pod to get to like uh I made
a Google doc and I was like what do you
do like I don't know for fun or
something like that like are you like
and you're one of your things was uphill
skiing or something yeah
I've got a buddy that's gotten into back
country skiing so that's like instead of
you know going to the resort riding the
lift up you're just sort of in nature
and you're fun nice thing everybody
likes yeah yeah you have to you know
manually get yourself up this hill so
um a few years ago he convinced me to go
do one of these things and it was in um
I think we're in Yellowstone Park we
didn't see another human the entire day
you're truly in the middle are you
hiking basically up a mountain
for this this was fairly tame so
basically it's a it's called a split
board what I use so it's a it looks like
a snowboard but it breaks down the
middle and the bindings rotate so it
basically turns into skis and then you
put these things on the bottom called
skins which originally I think used to
be Seal's skin is is where it came from
now it's just like some fancy Fabric and
it'll only slide one way so you can kind
of like slide up the hill with patches
you're like cross country skiing up the
hill and then it won't slide backwards
right so yeah you like fight your way up
the hill it takes several hours to do
this it's like a five minute ride down
so there's not a huge payoff there just
like little children coming down as
you're like brutally climbing yes and
then the cool thing you can do it at
Resorts too so our trip this year we
were at um Whitefish Montana and I was
doing this in the resort and you do get
a lot of respect from people coming down
the hill when you're like trudging up
the hill so it's a good feeling yeah
yeah no respect for me yeah
you are doing the wrong thing someone's
riding the lift up and down I don't even
get off this is but that was like to me
when I heard you say that I was like
checks out completely the way you
exercise or though like the way you
vacation basically is the way you work
which is just like Malik or grind and I
love that because that's if I mean if
you do that in any business you're gonna
increase the outcomes and so because we
still own like a good sized chunk of the
business
and so you know I wanted to know that
that was going to be worth something
someday and so that would be the only
way that I could make this deal worth it
was okay there's The Upfront cash and
all that good stuff that's great
but um your boy's gonna spend that I'm
gonna blow through that through you know
something
so I need to know that like the what if
what could have been will actually get
played out and like that way all just my
curiosity I'll know what would have
happened if we had kept at it and
focused on it well let me just
hand it to these guys who are super
focused and let's now we get to know uh
and then also there's you know uh you
get the reward of it too if it ends up
working out yep so that was one on your
side that's like that's my super problem
like this guy is literally willing to
climb up the hill like with this like
you know like he doesn't understand how
skiing works and enjoyment Works which
is great yeah and then it's like all
right so let's put this guy Kindle he's
the same way he's also just like this
absolutely not super grinder no
Kendall's Mr shortcut and I love this so
we were talking and I was like all right
um what you guys do before this before
this I kept digging tell the story of I
don't know let's pick one of them let's
do the uh the Tesla one the Tesla hack
because when she told me this story I
was like oh this guy's super clever he's
gonna find a way like he's just gonna
find the shortcuts that we would need to
like you know make this thing super
successful so tell that story yeah so I
had a Tesla and at the time they had the
Tesla referral program so basically they
gave every owner a unique code and to
get you know 5 000 supercharger miles
you actually had to use it so people
were searching for it and I was like
perfect I you know that's what I do for
a living I rank in Google so when you
search Tesla referral code my site was
number one I said what was it called
like trustworld.com no it was actually
Fair estimate.com okay I basically made
like for just a fun side project uh a
lift versus Uber comparison so you just
put like I'm going here you know what's
the difference between the two right and
so I just made a slash Tesla on that and
by the way that itself
that was another one of your little
shortcuts you didn't want to ever pay
for Uber again right like or Lyft
because you would just get referral
credits from that too right exactly so
basically on that site the way I
monetized it was here's my referral code
when you sign up for one or the other
and uh literally had unlimited Uber and
Lyft for years
literal years and I shared it with some
friends they'd be like hey you know I
want some can you put my code for a
little bit Yeah so I'd you know do it
for a month for them and they'd be like
I don't need it I am done and then it
would just be like the next round the
next friend that's hilarious but then
you know what happens is like these
programs are like okay this is kind of
weird you know there's certain codes
yeah exactly so they kind of cut you off
after a while but until then you kind of
can reap the benefits so you had to Uber
lift shortcut which was getting you free
Ubers and lifts
then you were like oh Tesla so you made
a slash Road or slash Tesla like
extension basically and you you were
ranking for when people were looking for
Tesla
exactly so I sent like hundreds of
people to buy cars and you needed to
send like I think 56 to get a Tesla
Roadster uh was that like the peak prize
that is the full program exactly but you
know I'm still waiting Roadster is like
what like 100 Grand or something it was
250. yeah oh yeah 200 or 250 depending
on like the money they never gave it
they never gave it to you well they
haven't released it what do you think oh
the New Roads new the newest yeah so
they were like hey when we do it you
know in 2019 you know we're gonna give
everyone so how many everyone win I mean
how much you earn so I earned like 1.75
I had sent more referrals but I think
Tesla was like all right you know we're
gonna give you 1.75 and then um what do
you do with the 0.75 I understand I
think you have to pay the you know the
difference between them when they do
um
I'll take the convertible thank you
and then um you know I did that and I
was like all right well hey Dad you have
a Tesla do you want a roadster
sure son I want that and so I put his
code and then did it with my
brother-in-law so you know we have a lot
of roadsters that might be coming
we'll see it's like the Oprah thing
yeah yeah that's amazing so you did so
you did that you also did other ones too
let's do some of the other ones you did
uh I was asking you how did you even
learned that there's like this like SEO
affiliate game right so SEO is just
people are searching for stuff on Google
if you can get to the top you're gonna
get a lot of free customer traffic
um and then affiliate is well what do
you do with that free customer traffic
they want something
you can pass that kind of qualified lead
that that high intent customer to the
website and they have affiliate programs
so you'll get the kickback that's how
you got the Roadster that's how you got
the Uber credits and all that so how did
you even figure out this was a thing uh
I want to hear that for both you guys
because this is this is y'all's game and
it's a game I didn't know about until
much later in life but you guys
discovered it kind of early I want to
hear the origin story how did you guys
even get into that yeah so this was like
during like the money maker you know
World Series of Poker was a big thing
and you know all of my friends and I
were playing poker just around the house
and then online you know there was a
bunch of poker sites and I saw one of
the poker sites had like a poker chip
set and they would give it to you for
free I was like well how does that work
nothing in life is free and I figured oh
they're giving it for free because
they're getting like 250 dollars per
person they end up sending so at that
point I was like perfect I've got a lot
of friends and I'm just going to kind of
make the difference I'll give them 50
bucks to deposit and I'll make you know
the 200 that I get paid from the uh you
know casinos and sports books and poker
at that point and so you do that with
like six friends
and ran out of them right you know it
was like it was it was great and then it
was like okay well now I need to
actually figure out how to do this
um and that's kind of how I got into
like oh I need to figure out how to
create websites I I can do this with
just like random people and you're
you're a teenager at this time I'm in
college yeah you're a college okay yeah
so I was in college Mike was actually a
teenager at that time and uh you know
just how to figure it out and I mean
like my first big break was actually
misspelling Paradise poker what do you
mean so how did that go down yeah well
so at the time when you searched in
Google they didn't have autocorrect so
basically you misspelled Paradise poker
and you'd get misspelled websites with
that and so I was like perfect I'm not a
very good speller so I can come up with
a lot of variations I couldn't tell you
to spell paradise poker right now
actually
and so I came up with a lot of
variations and you know got them to rank
and Google for like every misspelling
right and it was crazy because like all
of a sudden I just started seeing
traffic I started sending them obviously
to the real Paradise poker I made a cut
of them and literally my last year of
college it was like paid for I was
basically like parents like I've got
this you know I've got room board you
know education because I'm making free
money basically online were they like
well what do you mean
did they know about this the whole time
or not really I had to kind of like tell
them they were like I was a little
worried because I was like poker
gambling you know they're gonna be like
oh what's my son into is he doing this
right but my dad was actually like he
looked at me and he was like pretty
proud because he was like oh you're kind
of like you know the picks and shovels
right of it right you're not actually
doing it you're enabling people to do it
and the people that choose to do it yeah
and you you said you said something real
quick like we got to the top of Google
did you have to do anything interesting
to get your misspelled Paradise poker to
be the number one or was it just like
that was your domain name so it
automatically was going to be number one
at that time well the beauty of it was
there was just no competition no one
else was actually trying to misspell
Paradise poker on purpose maybe they
would misspell it once but I would have
it like eight times
so I was the best misspeller of paradise
poker and literally was number one for
most of the kids and essentially the
thing that's going on right now with the
Kia car where the Kia rebranded their
logo it looks like k n instead of Kia
and Google search for KN car is like
suddenly spiking because people see it
on the road they're like oh that's cool
what is that what is the KN car and I
was like this feels like a Kindle thing
and I was like Kendall what would you do
with this what was your answer so I you
know I had a buddy in Fleet Sales and
like that's where they you know sell a
ton of cars via online and I would make
a deal with someone like that at the
dealership I would say look I can get
you a lot of traffic and so I would
create websites that would literally you
know go for all the newest cars right
you know the 20 23 you know Kia whatever
it was but obviously spell it with the
KN right and then you know make a deal
with them like I'm going to send you
this you know I want 20 of all those
leads and what is your what would your
website look like at that time would it
be like hey this is the KN car go ahead
go buy her would you be like you know
would you just make it look like the Kia
website what would you actually do I
think I would just you know explain it
like hey you know it looks it says KN
but it's actually Kia and you know
here's the reasons why this car is
really cool and here's a form to
actually buy this car and I can get you
a great deal on it right and then you
know obviously send that lead over and
you know everyone's happy at that point
they actually find the car that they
wanted you know it wasn't Kia but you
know it was the KN car that they had
found how much you think somebody could
make if they they did this what's your
range what's your estimate of how that
would play out if you did a good job of
executing that I think if you did a good
job I mean the problem now is Google
autocorrect so Google Now I even did the
searches myself right it goes to the
actual Kia like hey I know what you're
trying to do right so you'd have to kind
of find that like where does doesn't it
do that is it the app store or is it
some like other you know place to do
that right and I think you could I mean
when you get like a really good
misspelling of really high priced items
with a decent margin you know you could
make hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's awesome man you kind of had a
similar origin story playing poker and
then discovered the poker affiliate game
yeah yeah so I was basically a
degenerate Gambler when I was 15 or 16.
um my friends and I would play you know
poker in home games just five ten bucks
whatever this is when poker was on TV
all the time right like 2005 and I just
kept losing all my money so I would have
to go to you know the local grocery
store to the Western Union or whatever
give them the 100 bucks cash they would
send it to you know Cambodia or wherever
it was going
um and then I would just lose that so I
was like I need to find some other way
to reload my my poker account because
I'm busted not I need to stop no exactly
where am I getting reloaded faster yeah
so then I saw it that they had like the
refer a friend thing on the website and
they would pay you like 75 bucks or
whatever to get your buddies to sign up
so I had all my friends sign up same as
you and when I ran out of friends I was
like same as I am like I got to figure
out a way to get strangers to do this
for me
and ended up coming across this uh Forum
called I think it was called poker
affiliate world back then it was
basically a lot of people who were doing
this that would share you know
what was working what wasn't it was a
very friendly community that I was kind
of surprised like I don't know why
people are telling me this but they're
kind of competing right yeah we were all
like we were competitors yeah and just
ended up becoming friends as well
um so just learned through doing that
start a website uh my I convinced my
parents to lend me like a couple hundred
bucks to buy a domain and set up you
know web hosting and everything and I I
told you this or I put in that document
that like when I've sold my first site
which was probably nine or 12 months
after that it was for thirty two hundred
dollars which was like a billion dollars
and I got all it was like a check I
cashed it I took all the cash home and
you know spread it out it's pretty good
out of
and then took the you know repaid my
parents and that was like a a very
sentimental moment for me that's amazing
did you have something for your neighbor
did something for you your neighbor like
lent you some money or something like
that
um was it like a lemonade stand story or
something like that well I like the
first thing I did for work my one of my
neighbors needed some like Landscaping
work done and I will give you you know
20 bucks or whatever to come over and do
it and it was on a Saturday and the
night before I was you know out with the
boys that I had a few sodas and uh I was
a little hungover that morning and I
made it to like 10 a.m before I had to
tap out like I just can't do this right
now that was that was the first and
probably only job you had yeah I just
had you know random stuff like that
um did that I had it I lasted one day on
a another neighbor had a a bread company
so they would have to deliver the bread
every morning to restaurants right and
my dad was friends with him so he's like
you know I'm sure trying to get me to do
something yeah you need to go work with
uh Mr anzavine for the day it was like a
4am wake up call to do that so it lasted
one day at that as well it's like
there's no way shoveled snow for one day
neither of you really had any real jobs
it sounded like you never had a real job
so you never had like a corporate go and
like you know here's your first day at
the new company you didn't have that I
did not I basically had like a summer
job it was like a temp job agency that
kind of places you different places and
one of them was like Dell warranties and
then I I realized then I was like I
can't work for someone else like this is
just not me uh you know I want to work
for myself I want to set my own hours
and I want to make a lot of money yeah
like my mom always said like when you
were younger all you said is like I want
to be a millionaire I want to make a
bunch of money and she was like all
right sure you know let's see what
happens but um you know that was just
kind of my general sense of it and I was
like I need to figure out a way to make
it like to make it also says something
like
I don't like the idea of working working
really hard and someone else making
money off that exactly I'm gonna make
the money off that I mean that's what
you know like being an employee right
like you're making the owner's money and
I just like I couldn't get like around
that I was like I need to be the owner
of the business dude I find it hard
sometimes to recruit people because I'm
like I fundamentally don't want to do
this
trade of like I get some security and
certainty and experience but you get the
upside you know like you know I get my
salary but you get the the upside of my
my work I I almost find it sometimes
hard to even recruit people to work at
this point because I'm just like I don't
know man I philosophically don't love
this path but then I also need to hire
employees all the time so I'm like you
know it's not because it's not very
productive you ever have that oh totally
and I feel like actually it's been
actually one of the most rewarding
things of my company is like watching
the people grow you know we would hire
them and I'd say like all right I just
need you to kind of you know write a
couple pages of content and then they do
a really good job it's like oh do you
want to be an editor of this website
right and then oh do you want to manage
other people and so like you know the
businesses I sold I made sure the people
that I was working with got really great
jobs because I feel like you know
sure I made a lot of the money but I
want to make sure that like your career
is set and you are in the best position
possible to really you know crush it or
you know with what you're doing
and what you do after your first sale
you did a a retirement party
yeah so I had this idea I was like okay
you know what I did it I'm done and you
were like 30 something 30 yeah it was
like 33 I believe and you know I was
telling all my friends like I'm gonna
rent out a restaurant and you know we're
just gonna like celebrate my retirement
and you know it'll be great because you
know I'm not going to be 65. I'll be
like 33 and it'll be great so we rented
out lazy bear in San Francisco and I had
all my friends and my family and it was
awesome we then had a party bus they
didn't even really know about your
business no I mean that was another
thing for me I've always been you know
not one to brag about it I feel like
what I do is kind of just what I do and
there's no reason to kind of be you know
boastful about it yeah so for actually
the first year after I sold the business
I didn't tell anyone
and and then after a year because I just
wanted to live with it and I just wanted
to kind of be comfortable with it myself
before I then told other people
um and so I had a three-year earn out so
after the three years is when I did my
retirement party
and so you sat on that news for a long
time I did yeah well yeah I sat on it
for a year told people but then I had
two years left with them once I was done
with that I was like it's retirement
time like I'm done let's do it so rented
lazy bear rented a bar had a party bus
and it was awesome but then literally
like three times were you at this party
you were supposed to come why did I not
come you had some some excuse I think I
was hungover again yeah this guy's
almost hung over I don't know what he's
talking about I can't remember why I
didn't come but I do remember that when
he did sell that one I had left the
gambling space so I I knew he was doing
well but I didn't know like what was
really going on and he was in Dallas for
something I can't remember what and I
went over to their hotel room and him
and his wife Tess had a ball of
champagne they're like we're gonna open
this celebrate the sale whatever I was
like oh you know congrats that's awesome
man and then I went home Google looked
it up and I was like oh and I text him I
was like all right I really mean it
because that's now like well we can it's
in the news right like that one sold for
I think 45 million it was actually 50
million total but I kind of sold it
twice to the company yeah which was kind
of a weird explain that how does that
work so first time you sold it for what
so first time I sold it for like 15
million plus you know a bunch of equity
and what happened was like at that time
New Jersey was big and that was like the
first legal state that had you know
casino and poker so we focused on that
we did really well let me explain
because I think people won't know the
context here so you go from online poker
then online poker collapses and now that
whole affiliate game is kind of dead
because you us just shut down online
poker
what most people did was they went
offshore or International because it was
still illegal in certain places or in
certain ways that's where most people
went and you did something different
like that was the obvious Market you
went for kind of a non-obvious pivot
which was
in the whole United States one state was
going to legalize
I don't know if all gambling or sports
betting which one they basically at that
point didn't have sports betting but it
was a poker it was casino and casinos
are like the big players so that's kind
of the one that was really exciting so
gambling was was legal in New Jersey and
only New Jersey and I remember at that
time it was like well how do you build a
business around one state that's it just
like it didn't sound big and I don't
think it sounded big to most people so
most people didn't do that right you
kind of like found the the hack that
nobody else was really competing for
this like
uh what was that what would be the
search term people were looking for that
you wanted to rank New Jersey online
casino was that was like the big one and
you're right like all of my competitors
were like perfect you know like we still
have 49 other states and The Regulators
at that time set if you choose to
promote in New Jersey you cannot do
anything else they didn't want you know
the the offshore plus the legal
regulated market and I was like that's
perfect I want to be you know a big fish
in a small pond so I started that
business it was going well but there was
one competitor Chris Grove and he was
really good at content and he had like
you know his game figured out I was much
more into the kind of Revenue side of
the business and so I talked and you
know we both talked for a while and
we're like you know this is what I'm
doing this is what I what I'm doing and
like we were like we're the only people
in this market
if we combine we basically own this
market right and so it was an easy
decision then you have pricing power
exactly because otherwise if you're an
affiliate and the company says Ah
instead of giving you 200 they'll give
you 20 you're just like well you're my
Revenue stream and you just changed the
price on me that's not great I think
that's one of the problems most people
in the affiliate game fall into is
you're you're at the whim of your
affiliate Partners but if you become
kind of like almost more important
you're like I'm the only acquisition
source for customers so this price is
the one I'm comfortable at exactly and
it was crazy because you know we were
able to get a thousand dollars per
player that we sent uh through New
Jersey online casinos wow and uh so yeah
it worked out really well for us
literally the first month we partnered
together we both made way more money
than we did apart and you know within
two years containing media the company
that purchased us uh you know came
knocking we're like we have to buy you
because we've heard at conferences we've
heard from you know people in the
industry that you guys are the biggest
and we want to own the biggest right so
they buy it once so they buy it once and
at that point it was just New Jersey and
what I told them I was like We're Not
Gonna sell like why would we sell we've
we have 49 other states that eventually
will legalize and so I came up with the
idea that all right we'll sell you New
Jersey
and any future state will get 50 of so
we'll be kind of 50 50 partners for
every stay right and they said sure they
didn't really care at that point I think
they were just more focused on New
Jersey and being the biggest affiliate
in the U.S market right
um so it was great we started running it
you know I had a three year and as I
mentioned the first year was good and
that's when sports betting actually got
legalized and then the business you know
started booming in terms of you know New
Jersey had it but then a lot of other
states were really excited about
offering it so they're you know to the
people in their state so they
um started legalizing and all of a
sudden basically we had like 10 states
coming online and the company was like
whoa
we cannot give you 50 of this this is
just too much liability
and so we're like okay yeah no problem
we you know here we just need a big chat
right
and they did and they were like we have
to we have to come up with a situation
that you know works for us and works for
you and so you know it was part stock
and part cash so in total is around 50
million yeah that's amazing and that
company is public listed right yeah I
mean they're publicly listed uh in the
Swedish Stock Exchange Swedish Stock
Exchange nice
um did you go ring like the bell and
Sweden like I I wish that would have
been
and so so that's kind of like your kind
of like the big win story let's do
Mike's big win story so
how does one go from I'm gambling and
losing money in poker I get my friends
to sign up for a referral program to I
own
this company that does like I don't know
multiple billions of
gold sales every year right so it's like
how does that happen where does that
come from Yeah so basically I was in the
gambling industry like he was and when
the [__] hit the fan I sold so I made
like the wrong call where that was like
the 3200 no so this was this was later
on I still I was further into it I sold
for 565 000. and I was I think 19 then
so to sell a business five or six five
thousand what was it doing at the time
like it must have been doing a lot but
the future was too uncertain it was
doing like 30 to 40K a month but it just
I didn't know what was gonna happen for
that so I sold that and then you know
I'm on top of the world yeah oh my God
you're how old you're like I'm 19 at
this point drop out of college yeah I
mean I'm going for it guys I figured it
out figured out life yeah so I'm like
all right I can do this affiliate thing
in any space so I try a bunch of
different plays I did it in the dating
space I tried to do it like selling
business cards online that was a
complete failure and just really like
was this where the spirit of ice thing
happened uh that was around that time
yeah
right so um when I you know around that
age when I was out that was at Penn
State I was having some fun uh and there
was this trend that was like icing
people so like smearing off ice right if
you first yeah
you present it to someone they had to
get on her knee and chug it so like guys
I knew at college and high school they
were into this by the way most genius
marketing campaign ever yeah it was so
someone needs to just redo that enough
time has passed just replay that same
thing yeah do a milk milk chug
back
a gallon of milk
um so
I there was a website called
brosicingbros.com where people would
send in like their best pictures of this
happening so they're all these creative
ones like there was one I remember where
a guy was super hungover in the morning
and went and opened his toilet and
they'd put plastic over the toilet
there's a Smirnoff Ice sitting there
yeah 7am so me and my buddies would send
these pictures back and forth like we
thought it was funny and then I just
somehow ended up reaching out to the guy
that ran it I was like I think this is
cool you know any interest in selling it
or you know do anything with it it ended
up working on a deal to buy it and I
gave him 25 000 for it there was no
monetization at all it was just like I
think this is cool it has a lot of
traffic I can figure something out here
and I'm really excited I tell my buddies
like yo I just bought that site right I
was like congrats yeah they're like we
want to get our pictures up whatever and
um the neck literally the next day I got
an email from Spirit offices we were
infringing their you know trademarks or
whatever and like you have to take all
the pictures off the site and the the
point of the site was the pictures not
the pictures so basically just shut that
down after 24 hours and just yeah wrote
it off didn't you try to blur it weren't
you saying you were going to blur it the
I talked to the prior owner because I
told him I was I was just like you know
any ideas and he's like well you could
try boring him out or whatever and it
doesn't seem a little coincidental yeah
did this guy make a phone call no wonder
but it's a nice loss for me nice
learning okay so you're the World's
trying to Humble you are you getting
humbled or not really you're just like
this very Teflon very successfully
humbling okay yeah it was it was kind of
like a two-year period where it just I
went from everything worked really well
so like nothing was working at all and
especially having uh you know I had left
school and my parents very much were
against that decision so it was it was a
dark time for me like you know is this
gonna work is it not am I going to get
egg on my face have to go back to
college whatever
um so one of the guys I knew from the
poker affiliate world he was doing some
affiliate websites in the the gold and
silver space and there was this company
that had just spun up an affiliate
program and a Jeremy Yankee a guy we
know was managing it for him so he's
like like you guys should look at this
whatever so I decided to invest in this
guy's business his name was Jonathan and
I was just going to help him like build
these sites let's see if we can turn it
into something and over like maybe six
or nine months we build up some traffic
it was making like five grand a month
you know it was it was a side thing for
me I was trying to do other stuff and
um kind of out of nowhere the company we
were sending everybody to just killed
their whole affiliate program so we went
from making you know 5K a month to just
zero you know this looked like another
just completely flown got iced again
yeah Mike gets iced yeah
um and then my partner like credit to
him I was I was again was being just
like well there's nothing to really do
here there's no other affiliate programs
um we had actually gone to that company
that cut us off and and offered to sell
them the website like you know this
thing was sending you I don't know 200
buyers a month or whatever it was you
know just kind of backing into what
you're paying us on an affiliate basis
just give us 40 grand for it and we'll
you know you can have lead gen for a
long time and they just never replied to
us so we you know we had no path to
monetizing it so I was yeah I was
writing it off and then my partner is
like we should just sell this stuff
ourselves and that sounded like you can
imagine how much of a nightmare that
sounds insane if you're an affiliate
because you never talk to customers you
don't like there's no employees really
like it's a very simple business there's
no product yeah it's it's you're kind of
a middleman yeah you're like in between
people and the product yeah so I I was
like this is crazy I don't want to do
any of this but he's like I'll do all
those like gasps in the Affiliates real
business
exactly yeah so beautiful products there
so he's like I'll I'll do all the
inventory shipping customer phone calls
all that stuff I'll do it all like you
just help with get traffic and put some
more money in yeah so I was like all
right let's give this a try and so yeah
I mean credit to him it wouldn't happen
if he hadn't pushed so hard this is uh
this is Andrea so this is somebody this
is Jonathan so that was the JM was
Jonathan and Mike okay and Kind of a
Funny Story sounds very Regal and
official like great story Jonathan and
Mike's gold shop versus JM bullying like
that's a so step up we knew so little
about this space when we started that we
named it J.M boy and using our initials
and we had no idea that like one of the
largest refiners of gold and silver in
the world is Johnson Matthey and so we
actually got a big boost early on
because people thought we were there
retail art like it was a nice little
accidental win and we didn't get any
cease and desist so that's nice
um so yeah we spin this thing up uh it
went live I think October of 2011 and
the the idea was we're just going to
point all our old traffic at the new
e-commerce site jmboyan.com and it was
it was crickets the first few weeks like
zero or I don't think we got an order
for three weeks and I honestly think
that was like my mom's friend who like
told him to go do it or something
um but you don't give up at that point I
didn't give up and you know just kept
trying to figure stuff out how can we
make this work what's that conversation
like you're three four weeks in
you go to the office like does anybody
say anything like hey guys uh yeah well
there was no office so that was easy
it was my partner had all this success
yeah no office my partner had all the
gold in this little dust Jordan his
basement it could all fit in like the
tiny little okay so you're in the
basement you're like yeah no gold is
leaving the drawer right now staying in
the drawer
um it was so early that it I wasn't
really worried at that point you know
you like what we're doing right now it's
early you know you're you know it takes
years to build these things
um but we they're kind of a funny story
on this we eventually out of nowhere
start getting like big orders and we
didn't change anything so we're very
confused as to what's going on here big
credit card orders uh repeat customers
over and over and over we're like all
right we've we've hit it like this is
gonna work and so for like two months
this goes on we're getting like 100 200k
Revenue a month or no I'm sorry it
wasn't that much it was probably 30 or
50 Grand and literally on Christmas
morning my partner texts me he's like
kind of weird have you seen the the
checking account it's like no I go and
pull it up on my phone like Christmas
morning with my family around yeah both
the checking account were like negative
forty thousand dollars all of it was
fraud every single order was like credit
card chargeback fraud we just didn't
know anything about any of this stuff so
we had so many of those moments along
the way where it was really just two
kids you know figuring out how to run a
gold business and there were a lot of
pitfalls that we fell into and
fortunately didn't kill us so all right
so you recover from that yeah so I had
to put more money in I was pretty much
on the ropes at this point right it was
it was like everything that was going in
now this was this was it this was gonna
work or you're stressing I'm stressing
at this point yeah and this is where you
start uphill skiing in general yeah so
the really the turning point for that
company was
I just took a really honest look in the
mirror and I said here's JM here's like
the five biggest companies like if I
look at these various you know metrics
or whatever you hug us their website
how's their pricing product selection
how fast do they ship customer service
whatever and I just basically like did a
little scorecard for everybody and I was
like there's no reason anyone would ever
buy from us we're just worse at
everything we have less selection we
didn't even we were so small we couldn't
get a wholesale account right so we were
just buying from the cheapest retailer
and marking it up
um you know me and Jonathan were
answering the cell phone that was our
cell phones were the 800 number you know
if we were available we'd answer it was
just again like why would someone buy
from us so what I landed on I was like
the only lever we can really pull here
is we're just going to undercut everyone
because this is a commodity and it's
like buying gasoline if there's a if
there's a store here in a store there
and that one's a penny cheaper you're
going to pull in there so I'm like let's
just cut it and see what happens because
if we can get volume and you know make
that work and see the Top Line grow I
know we're going to be able to figure
out margin as we as we go you know
you're going to get economies of scale
um so we did that and that did work and
then we started to see the revenue
really grow so through 2012 we were
starting to do like you know a million
plus a month in sales which back then we
were really pumped about
and the problem with this company was it
was super Capital intensive because you
had to stay ahead of the inventory right
so like if you were going to be able to
ship fast it had to be you know in the
drawer when they order
so I I did another round I put I think
my last 100K in basically and then we
outgrew that and I was like we need
someone no bank's gonna give us any
money we put a deck together and send it
to like 60 different you know uh Angels
or VCS and just zero responses
absolutely not even like a no thank you
um so I was thinking like who could I
get to invest in this thing and I uh
called him and so he was our first angel
investor you knew him personally at the
time yeah so because we were competitors
in the in the space and we went to all
the conferences together and we were
both around the same age and you know
just like to you know go out have
dinners and stuff at conferences
um so we were friends and he had told me
after I sold my gambling business he's
like you know whatever you do next let
me know I would like to invest so I was
like you get the call I was like hey
yeah I gotta cash that in now what
happens you get the call what's your did
you even know he was doing this in the
meantime I did you know I got it I was
excited about being able to be a part of
it but I was like I don't want to be
operational like you know for me I was
just like I'm trying to do this gambling
business us you know and but I'm excited
about Mike you know Mike made really
good websites and I was like if anyone's
gonna figure it out it's going to be
Mike and so basically I invested in him
and
um you know it was I I feel like we had
a quick negotiation it was like 24 hours
yeah you did a great deal and he had all
the leverage it was like we were either
gonna go under or he was going to write
this check so it's always like so you
got an A plus for that yeah
and it was like just speed it was
affiliate you know we always call like
affiliate speed where it was just like
we had kind of had a handshake agreement
and then I just wired in the money like
we probably didn't do anything yeah yeah
but it was like I trust you you put in
what like a couple hundred K or I think
100 it was it was a hundred and then you
this was another a plus move he
negotiated like another Rider of like I
get to do another 50 at this same
valuation at my option which he then did
a few months later as we were growing
okay so you put it 150k yeah that ended
up being a good return for you like
what's the multiple on that
I think it was at what 20 million you
got like 23 million yeah
you that's what you've met it out yeah
I'm not sure about the valuation no
because like in Silicon Valley it's like
oh you invested a seed thing oh is that
a 20 million valuation no no you're
saying
it was maybe a million bucks
we said it was worth a million no maybe
700k or something was evaluation and
yeah I sold it for 175. so you got
amazing return there he turned up 100K
ish into 20 million thanks Mike yeah
yeah I mean do you uh
you know we can do another business
together right I'll actually help this
time yeah there you go that was good
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better so you okay
so you do that that's amazing you get
the phone call you do that you get this
more money but it seems like you're just
gonna have this problem again and we did
like three months later so we get his
last you know 50 or whatever it was and
then we were really this it was starting
to grow pretty quick at that point we
were up to probably 4 million a month in
revenue and it was starting to hockey
stick so I was like you know what are
you doing to get so much traffic it's
SEO basically yeah so that's when the
SEO really started to kick in so
initially it was like we're gonna we're
gonna price cheaper we're gonna make
this appealing to people and then people
start you know we get the return
customers get the backlinks going the
site what do you call this exercise you
did where you're like I took an honest
look in the mirror and I said it's kind
of like why would it yeah I want to date
a 10 why would a 10 date that's exactly
that right that's basically what you
were saying it's like they have all
these websites they can choose from why
would they be choosing us
should more companies do that I feel
like most companies don't actually do
that exercise because it can be painful
because the answer often isn't what you
want it to be right the mirror doesn't
look that way it's not that the world is
wrong and dumb
so that's you know something I've tried
to use over my career and it's been
helpful that's amazing um yeah I think
more people should do that exercise and
and also when you do that I think it uh
it forces Clarity where are we going to
be great you know we're what are we
going to be great on and you decided
we're gonna be great on price first and
then we're going to be great on these
other things later
okay so you do that grows grows grows
you do this for eight years you sell
Hallelujah
um so that's kind of like your your big
wins I want to know give me some stories
along the way on either of the big wins
maybe a story of uh
you know something that you look fondly
at in the early days of like you know
one of those like wins along the way
that felt really good and then maybe a
moment that felt bad I don't know if you
have any stories on either one of those
I'd love to hear them yeah
um this was kind of a mix of good and
bad but so that first year I think it
was before you were in we had gotten an
order from a guy it was for like twenty
thousand dollars which was a big order
for us back then and he pays us we ship
it you know it's delivered everything's
fine we go on our way and then we hear
from him like a week later that you know
I was out of town There's No Gold here
you know I don't know what happened here
and again we were so naive we didn't
even have like shipping Insurance back
then so this there was just nothing
there
um so we dug in pretty firm we're like
you know UPS has the GPS coordinates on
your doorstep you know the driver has
signed an affidavit that he delivered it
there you know all this stuff but this
guy just kept digging in harder and he
he did this like there's a site called
ripoffreport.com okay anyone can go on
there and file like hey this per company
or person screwed me and he did that and
we were so early that like there were no
jam boy in reviews anywhere so when
people searched that that was the number
one thing that came up and it
immediately hit us like probably 30
percent of our sales just fell off
because everyone in the gold space
everyone checks right like they're
always worried about getting you know
yeah so it was really hurting us and
this guy then went into like this kind
of sob story of you know that was my
kids college fund my kid's not going to
be able to go to college you're going to
ruin his life unless you make this right
whatever
and I was really starting to stress
about this you know that's not a good
feeling and I don't know this person but
you wouldn't want anyone to feel like
that so as this draws on and we're not
finding a conclusion UPS basically is
like we delivered it you know we're
washing our hands of this thing
um I had caved in and I was like I'm
gonna personally write this guy check
for 20. and that would have been like
the end of my checking account right
there and because I couldn't even sleep
at night I was feeling so much guilt
about this and so I had I drafted the
email that I was going to send to him
and I was like I'm gonna sleep on this
one more night just to be sure and that
morning I woke up and UPS had gone with
the police to his house and as soon as
the police were there he found it in his
closet
so that one had a you know a happy
ending thankfully but uh that was
another warning moment for us of like
okay well obviously we need to figure
out the delivery and insurance business
painful painful Lessons Learned but you
got to do it so I think uh one would be
uh base boom and face the or
facebook.com
wait what okay so what are these so at
the time originally it was the
facebook.com that was you know
Facebook's domain name and you know I
was in college so I was part of it and
eventually they dropped the
and I knew like right away I was like
I'm in a domain squat on things that
they're gonna type wrong you know
Paradise poker you know same thing but
I'm gonna do it for Facebook so I got
the K is by the m so that's why I
registered Facebook like on the keyboard
oh you're a man
ifest
we'll forget so they you know they you
know end up putting the com and then.com
again and the crazy thing about it was I
got to see basically Facebook's like
growth crazy hockey stick by the way I
just went to facebook.com you know where
it goes I have no idea Facebook it goes
to Facebook now they also figured this
out yeah so that they might have figured
out one way but at the time I actually
ended up selling facebook.com for like
20K you know someone came and was like
hey there's a lot of traffic coming here
you know at that time you'd have just
like you know PPC type ads just like
really basic text link ads and you'd
make like you know 10 cents per click
but there was enough traffic where it
made it worthwhile
um so I sold it to them and I was like
sweet I still have you know facebook.com
I'm excited to sell this one but little
did I know like a big old packet of
papers comes from Facebook and they're
like hey
that's our trademark right do you want
to fight this or do you want to hand it
over and it was a very easy choice to
give them the domain name so at least I
got to sell one of them that's pretty
good did you uh you got to tell the I
switch story what was that one
well I almost went blind
or at least I thought I was I thought
this was gonna be a misspelling like not
twitch.com I twitched it so like on my
first company you know the regulator
said as I mentioned you can't do
offshore if you're gonna do regulated
you have to do regulated and one of my
competitors I think
told on me and said I think Kendall's
joined both
and so I was like okay and so I didn't
know any of this and I was at an
industry conference and one of The
Regulators was like hey I'd like to meet
you for coffee I was like all right is
this something I should be worried about
right he's like no no no just just come
it's like when Chris Hansen's like
pizza's inside come on in
you don't go for the pizza so I just
thought you know I walk up there we sit
down and I think this is going to be a
really friendly conversation and he's
like
so we can do this the hard way or the
easy way and uh like at that time I'm
like stunned I'm just kind of like oh no
do I run
and so then he's like you know what you
know we've had reports that we think
you're doing the offshore and you know
what are you gonna say about this and at
that time I was like I'm not gonna say
anything you know I'm not gonna
incriminate myself but I but it was
wrong you know all like these Pages were
basically
um algorithmically updated with these
offshore ads that I had no control over
right but he didn't know that because he
wasn't really familiar with domain
parking Pages Etc but at that time I was
like
I need to talk to my lawyer yeah and
then we can talk to you and you have a
lawyer figure it out I did not happen
to tell me that I need to say these
words
exactly so then I mean that was a you
know terrible feeling but I was like
okay you know what I'm gonna talk to a
lawyer we'll be able to kind of outline
you know why you know what he thinks is
not actually happening
um but then I get a email from them and
they're like we need you to come to New
Jersey
and I was like oh no they want to arrest
me they want to get me in their
jurisdiction and they are going to
arrest me
um and at that time I was like
I was like talking to my wife Tess like
there's something wrong with my eye
and she's like oh you know it'll be fine
and I was like yeah I think it'll be
fine but I'm like kind of seeing a
little specks and it like got worse and
worse and at one point I was like I
can't read a menu
um and I went to it then so I went to a
specialist an eye specialist and he
thought I had a detached retina and he
was like oh my gosh we got to get you
into surgery and all these other things
and then so then he kind of looked a
little harder and was like
no no actually have you been stressed
lately
very stressed very very stressed and
he's like yeah you know we've seen this
you know it's just a common thing you're
just stressed you'll be fine
so to end the story I had to go to New
Jersey talk to the regulators and I
wanted to bring a lawyer
and they're like nope don't bring it
just sued them for the twitch yeah
exactly if you Blinded Me with Your hard
way easy way [__] at the coffee shop
and they're like do not bring a lawyer
because we'll make it hard on you
I was like oh my god oh they told you
that yes they told me that so man I
wouldn't know what to do yeah I wouldn't
know okay am I are they just is this a
play is this a good cop back up type are
they pushing me around or is this real
yeah I had no idea but I was just like
all right no lawyer like I mean I'm
gonna listen to them this time but which
is funny because the first time they you
know hey everything's all right and just
come see us and I sit there I'm at the
office I'm looking around I'm like okay
I've been arrested yet which is good
they sit down and they're like okay well
talk to us about you know being an
affiliate and then it was like this
super cordial conversation and I ended
up saying like Okay yeah these few
things weren't what they seemed and
here's why and then they're like okay
you know that's fine but you know we
just want to learn more about Affiliates
because they were like you know the
first Regulators in the United States
and they had never really talked to a
large affiliate and because you know we
were the only one at that point right so
then they just kind of wanted to you
know do a fact-finding mission and it
all worked out I didn't go blind and you
know I'm here today so I feel like
you're either been blinded in jail and
you ended up not blinding out in jail
did you like pack a jail bag
I did not but my wife was in a hotel and
I was just like okay well you know we
have enough clothes if we need
that is amazing
you guys are also kind of like life hack
life experimenters I feel like you got
just like you like finding the clever
angles in business I feel like you do
that with with life of like you don't
just do things exactly the way others do
then you're like well why don't I just
do this you know instead uh and you've
done this yeah I feel like you do the
same thing with certain you know like I
don't know lifestyle experiments so tell
us about some of those what are some
things that you guys do with your
day-to-day life that is maybe just not
standard not not exactly what anybody
else is doing because I think for people
listening they and myself included I
love hearing when people don't just like
follow a you know a very standard
Playbook because it makes me wonder oh
what's the thought process behind that
why do they do that and nine times out
of ten I don't do it myself but I like
hearing those do you guys have any uh
kind of like interesting lifestyle
choices or experiments that you do
I think the first one for me was you
know I was having twins and I was
telling my wife like look we're having
twins this is insane she's like yo I
know yeah she's like they're in I have
to do the brush actually I'm having
twins
and I was like we need to get some help
like we need experts and so what I did
was you know I talked to an agency and I
just kind of
you know cast my net wide and far and I
was like I want to find someone that can
help us race these kids so you took this
seriously like on your to-do list was
like I'm going to do a search I told an
expert you're doing the hard part I'll
do the easy part and just try to find
someone that has done this before that
can really help us along the way and
really like kind of make our lives
easier and I found this twin expert she
actually lived in New Jersey
and we ended up hiring her for four
months for the baby's first four months
and she basically worked with them like
night and day 18 hours a day with them
and you know part of it was training us
you know with like a dog you know
they're like oh you know you don't train
the dog you train the person and it was
kind of the same with us and really she
put them on like an insane schedule
where if one was sleeping the others one
was sleeping if one was eating the other
one was eating and now they're like
super trained so after four months they
slept through the night and you know
they were just like very schedule
oriented we'd like look at the time it's
like two o'clock okay they need to eat
right now and they were like ready for
they were both just just totally ready
to sleep at the same time at the exact
same time like always so they really
kind of synced up and that Lit made life
so much easier because I couldn't
imagine right then it's like yeah yeah
exactly we basically have like one kid
that ends up being too
that's amazing what about you
yeah I mean I followed him on some of
this stuff so he after he sold he
um one of the splurges was he hired a
chef so I cooked for him and when I
heard that I was like oh that sounds
really like bougie I don't know I don't
know yeah that sounds cool I don't know
and then
um he was homie about it and I was like
yeah this makes a lot of sense like why
would I can eat healthier you know I
don't have to think about it I don't
have to think about what I'm gonna eat
Etc
um so I ended up finding somebody as
well and then I've come out to see him a
few times the last few months and when
we'll be eating I can like see him
looking at me because he's so
competitive I know he wants to know like
is this better than what I'm eating at
home ah sadly the answer is yes but
you're never given that satisfaction
that's just that finally messed up
messed up yeah that's amazing yeah you
uh you're a foodie and you so for you
it's like all your food that makes sense
but actually you're more of like an
efficiency guy and so you know people
don't really realize how much mental and
physical energy goes into
feeding yourself three times a day or
feeding in my case kids also and so we
have a chef as well and it's the same
same thing it's like all right if I just
don't have to make decisions and I eat
healthier and it tastes better because
I'm not good at cooking this person's
great at cooking I was like any money I
could spend on a car a nice nice
whatever
um I would way rather do this I would
rather have one less employee at work
and do more myself than than like
sacrifice on this for sure yeah and it's
like I think we've both gotten a lot
better at you know if you have a problem
you can think about how can I fix this
problem like how can I solve the problem
tactically or whatever or you can just
think about who can fix this for me and
and that path is you know he's so much
more efficiency for you you can focus on
your superpower and you know it's
obviously been what we've done and you
guys you guys are different and uh for
most people who come on the show and
also most people I hang out with because
I'm you know we're here in San Francisco
it's mostly Tech Silicon Valley and Tech
is not like like here's like we build
websites but anybody who works in Tech
here would be like what do you mean
you're like you're making a WordPress
site with a referral link what do you
that's not like software uh you know
it's not a software startup in the same
same vein that most people consider
um and you guys also don't go raise
money from Venture capitalists you don't
like you don't do a lot of the [__] that
like Silicon Valley companies do what do
you guys see as like what do you like
about that they're like oh maybe I
should start doing some of that and what
parts are you like no my way is
different but I think it's better for
these reasons do you guys have any
opinions on that yeah for sure um so I
like I grew up in Buffalo New York and I
just was never exposed to any of that
stuff so I didn't know what I didn't
know so I was just trying to figure out
how can I do what I'm trying to do
um actually meeting you and spending
more time out here has opened my eyes a
lot to that side of the world I think
you know for us the benefits of finding
it ourselves are you know obvious we
control it there's there's no one else
that's asking us you know do this or do
that or where's this Revenue Target Etc
so we can think really long term about
the business and I love that you know
we're the decision makers and we move
fast so it's like once decision needs to
be made it's like hey what do you think
here's what I think all right let's go
um I think one thing you probably lose
though is it's in my opinion it's harder
to have like the really big outcome if
like the things we're doing or
historically have done it it's hard to
be like a 10 billion dollar company from
that stuff and I think going the other
path you know it's still very very rare
but it does happen right you don't hear
a lot about they just self-funded this
the whole way and then iPod it for 100
billion dollars right that doesn't
really happen so and I think two you
lose time
like for us it was always like we always
wanted to operate the business
efficiently and profitably so things
would take time and you you'd watch
another competitor you know raise a
bunch of money and do some really
exciting things and you're like that's
really cool that's not me at this point
but I can see the merits of it
but I think for me I've always been like
I'm just again a control freak and I was
like I don't want to work for someone
else and I think with VC it's kind of
the same thing right like that is part
of it and you know with this acquisition
I feel like you're on our team like you
know it's I don't feel like it's kind of
you know you're going to be on the board
and we're going to be able to make
really big decisions together rather
than hey I invested in you I just you
know are we 10 times yet you know like
that type of thing yeah yeah totally and
what about um
you know I guess like business
philosophies so I've heard as we've been
talking some like some of your guys is
like isms it's like oh these are
kendalisms these are mychisms of like
but I've only worked with you for a very
short amount of time so I don't know a
lot of them yet but I'm sure you have
them right nobody goes through years and
years of building businesses without
coming up with some operating philosophy
of like you know here's how it'll work
here's how to negotiate here's how to
build here's how to like stay the course
or whatever do you guys have any that
stand out to you as like you know these
are my like these are kind of my pillar
ones this is like I just really believe
this and I can kind of tell a story that
maybe goes along with that one and it's
a bit of a hard question but I find
these if you do have an answer I find
this to be a really valuable one yeah
I mean for me I feel like you're gonna
be right a couple times in your life
and if you think you're gonna be right
swing big
um you know for example with domain or
with
um Bitcoin
I you know I saw it I was super
interested in it I was like this could
be really cool or well you could time
frame are we talking this is 2013. okay
you know this could be really cool or it
could go to zero but I have this like
inclination that it could be you know
way bigger and I think it has a chance
too and it kind of brings me back to my
dad and this is in the 90s he was a
computer programmer and he was like
telling our family like domain names are
going to be big and I was like oh that's
cool dad yeah you know and he was like
no they're going to be big every person
or company are likely going to want one
and he bought our last name seville.com
but didn't really buy anything else at
that point right he could have bought I
looked it up like poker.com he was right
but didn't swing hard exactly and so
when I was looking at Bitcoin I was like
this is my you know domain names
um so I just started buying Bitcoin and
I was like I am just gonna like you know
hold it and just see what happens what
you know no matter what I don't want
that you know I wish I didn't sell right
so I'm still holding it today and you
you you're a bit bigger at that time
um all right I shouldn't say you bet big
because you don't often have to put 100
of your chips on on it because it's like
this is one that it can go big so I
don't even need to put you know my
entire stack in it I just need to put
enough
or if this works it means something yeah
right like yeah no I I mean I really
didn't I probably put a couple hundred
thousand dollars in at that point yeah
but I was like you know I'll just wait
it out at that point I think it was
around 80 to 90 dollars per Bitcoin and
then now you've seen ups and downs and
ups and downs along the way did you
feel tempted to sell or to you know like
get out exit either either because I got
a bunch of profit or
oh man bad news bad news bad news bad
news bitcoin's crashing maybe I should
just get out not really I feel like you
know it was always like oh there's gonna
be a huge tax set and you know so when
it was really high you know that's what
I feel like and then as it's low I'm
like it could still you know I still
think it's got a long ways to go right
so I for me I'm just like this is a long
hold and uh you know we'll see when that
changes but I mean that's why we started
this company you know we're really
excited about crypto and we think
there's a big future here so at this
point I'm just gonna you know I might
die with it I remember when um so I
discovered about the same time 2013 2014
and um I won't tell you the whole story
but like let's just fast forward a
little bit so I buy a little bit of
Bitcoin I'm like all right great I'm in
the game baby and um
there was a run where Bitcoin went to I
was buying it like 400
400 was like my average Buy price and
then Bitcoin runs up to uh 3 000 at the
time
and
I go to a wedding and I go to my
cousin's wedding
and my aunt so imagine like an Indian
Auntie like you know she's just like not
who you not
somebody who I would think would say the
word like Bitcoin or ethereum she said
the word ethereum actually so I was like
what the hell
um and she was like oh yeah bitcoin's
very good and I was like oh why do you
why do you say that and I was like
immediately my face just dropped because
I was like
there's no way that she is like the one
who's on the trend and she's like yeah
it's very good and I was like what and
yeah it goes up and I was like that's
the whole thinking like she's like yeah
last month it was this now it's this and
before that it was even lower it was
like
oh my God this is like a bubble and I
was like I had read about this bubble
[__] like because I graduated 2010 so I
missed the whole.com bubble by a long
shot I missed 2008 crisis I was a
sophomore in college I didn't care what
was going on in the world and so I was
like I think this is one of those bubble
things and I was like you know what
maybe I should take some profits and so
I go and I try to sell everything on
coinbase but coinbase thank God how much
you could sell at a time and so I like
maxed out the limit for one week and I
think I did it for another week and I
was like I'm getting exhausted like by
the end of like the fear had like
dissipated or whatever
and the Bitcoin runs up to 20K and I'm
like you know I'm like oh my God I'm the
biggest city and then it crashed it back
down I was like wow I have to really
have a bit more of a
of a plan as to what I'm gonna do with
this am I able to hold this forever am I
going to hold it to a certain point what
is driving my belief in this so that I'm
not just at the whim of like oh I hear
something and I it scares me the taxi
driver told me something and it made me
bullish or bearish or whatever on it
um we're at a point right now where
probably sentiment about crypto is like
I don't know at the lowest it's been and
maybe ever but definitely uh Lowe's has
been a while and for a lot of people
they don't they weren't around for the
14 crash or whatever this 18 crash it
was like this is their crash where
they're like oh crypto turned out to all
be a scam I guess FTX is a I don't know
what was wrong with all this so that's
kind of where people are at
um what gives you what is your belief
based on for crypto like why do you
think this is going to be a thing
I feel like digital money needs to be a
thing like we were literally trying to
wire money into this company and it
wouldn't work and it was just like what
you know like what do you mean it
wouldn't work what was happening well it
was Mike had the real issue but it took
you a week so we we both use the same
exact Bank we're with City
yeah and
um same exact wiring instructions this
is just a PDF we both send them to our
you know people there said I want to
wire whatever it was into the company
the next day I get the notice from
Mercury his hits and I sent mine like
four hours before his and I the whole
day I never saw mine come in so I'm like
that's weird they had called me you know
I did yeah I answered all the questions
I had to do the DocuSign like text you
know to auth all this stuff
where it never goes so I finally have to
reach out to them again and I'm like
what's going on with this and they come
back to me and say
the wire instructions are wrong and I'm
like well the same bank with the same
PDF said I sent the money so that was an
example where like on crypto that would
have been a 10 second you know
transaction so I I agree with him you
know I'm probably even more into the you
know don't love the government control
over all of the fiat currency stuff I
think we're seeing you know we're
starting to see and we're probably going
to see more of the ramifications of that
with you know debt inflation those sort
of things and you know having another
option I think is nice right yeah so in
the same way like uh government makes
all the rules of where you live great
but if you don't like the way that the
government makes those rules you have a
choice you can move to a different
jurisdiction you can operate by
different rules uh if you don't like the
way that the government manages the
money system by printing more money or
whatever it may be
then you could opt into a different
monetary system that's not controlled by
the government that's controlled by you
know a set of source code and the code
you know lives and runs on its own and
anybody from anywhere in the world can
say you know what I don't like my
country's monetary system as my base
system I'm going to opt into this one
that makes a lot of sense to me
why do you think people have like such a
like what do you think or maybe let's
not put this put it this way what do you
think are the fair criticism so
um if you heard of the phrase steel
Manning but like you know it's like when
you argue the other side in good faith
you say here's the here's the best
argument I could see against it what
would that be for for crypto I think
like a big one is there are a lot of
scammers in the industry and you know
they're able to do that because they
don't have a lot of the checks and
balances of the current system and I
think there's a lot of good reasons why
that's the case in crypto but also it
allows these people to do these kind of
Nefarious things
um you know I was telling people
recently I was like you know what crypto
does look really bad like there's no you
know you can't really argue that fast
right but cryptos look really bad you
know a lot of times but then at other
times it looks really good you know
there are by the way it wasn't Bitcoin
that did something bad right yeah
exactly you have to sort of separate the
two right like um if somebody runs a
real estate scheme and scams their
investors and you're you think you're
investing in some property they're just
pocketing the money and running away
with it or they you know they do
something bad to the property whatever
it's not real estate that was the scam
it was the scammer that was the scam and
I think that's the hard part is that
crypto has
such a playing field right it's a money
business so so many people that can scam
so it almost Associates Bitcoin or the
underlying thing itself which is you
know it's like a rock it's like it's not
doing anything
it Associates that with the scam even
though it was the human being who
decided to trick people in order to make
that happen right like that that's the
I think that's the the hard thing to
disentangle yep
do you um
what was your reaction to like all the
[__] that was going down right we're in
the slack Channel talking about you know
the daily Edition and it feels like you
know Bad News Bears for like you know 30
days in a row Mike what you were living
in each of those editions yeah were you
what did you go were you surprised with
the FDX thing what was your reaction
yeah I was stunned by that I mean that
you know I like a lot of people viewed
them as you know almost like a coinbase
blue chip rock solid if you don't feel
good putting your money on there I would
have recommended them to anyone so I I
was really shocked same with Genesis
yeah we have I have money on Genesis
that I don't know what's going to happen
to it but that one was pretty stunning
too
um well it's been interesting for the
milk Road and our businesses
you know this has actually been for
growth a good thing right we cover the
news and there's certainly been a lot of
news so we're seeing you know record
Subs coming in that the reader scores
have been really good people seem to be
very interested in following this
despite the fact that it's been very you
know negative so you know some other
piece of why we liked your business it's
less correlated in our minds directly to
crypto prices yeah yeah that's true yeah
um amazing uh do we leave anything that
we should have should have talked about
we miss any good stories or uh
or facts that you guys wanted to cover I
don't think I have anything nothing all
right well where should people find you
guys because I think a lot of people are
going to listen yeah these guys are cool
obviously milk road but like where do
they find you guys personally I know
Mike you congratulations did you tweet
for the first time today I had my first
tweet today first tweet yeah first tweet
about acquiring the mocha my Twitter
handle is Mike Whitmire which Kendall
helped me acquire earlier so last night
it's like the news is going out to this
morning and Mike's like hey um uh
anybody can help me every round to help
me figure out how to tweet uh I've never
really tweeted let alone a thread it's
like is there a button for the thread
yeah and it was all I did was just laugh
yeah I provided zero help I was like
yeah this is hilarious I'm like you're
the expert I'm not doing anything no
this is hilarious basically Ben helped
me out but it was like a [__] show for
both of us he sends his out this morning
he misspelled milk Road
just trying to get that autocorrect
exactly I'm just trying to you know
figure out a way but yeah I totally
misspelled it and then I deleted the
first tweet because
it's still there and I didn't realize it
for like 20 minutes and everyone's like
what is wrong with your Twitter profile
I'm like I don't know I think Twitter's
messed up but you at least use Twitter I
do use Twitter more than Mike but I
wouldn't say I'm like I think you should
actually make your Twitter bio because
you have no picture or you had no
picture so I added a picture oh yeah you
should keep the no picture no tweets
just the thread and your bio should be
um I don't tweet I do actual work that
should be your whole Persona and
everybody should follow that and that's
actually you asked earlier about why we
don't do that stuff and something that
came to mind for me was do you remember
back in the day in the poker affiliate
world where all the like mid-tier to
small Affiliates had their like blogs
yes like the personal blogs so everybody
like I had like Mike whitmire.com right
you had something I think yep and we
would all you know Muse about what we
were doing our business is this and that
doing these posts feeling good and then
we were at one of these conferences and
who was the the big Jam investor and he
was like the biggest poker affiliate
probably in the world back then
and this other guy that was similar
neither of those guys did any of that
stuff and like every night we're out in
the clubs at these guys tables you know
hoping they'll give us like their drinks
and it was kind of eye-opening for me
I'm like there's probably a correlation
here maybe I should do with those again
maybe I should do the work
can you tell any of his stories because
this guy sounds like a legend who who is
this person he's definitely a legend
what are some of the the craziest yeah
yeah he's a pretty private guy but he um
he's got a great story also by the way
we could bleep his name yeah okay so
then he could just be like you can tell
the story without the name all the good
stories
um so uh crazy story he's from he grew
up there very uh not well off very poor
had to leave school in eighth grade
um so I go start making money for his
family whatever
um what did he do in the eighth grade uh
he was like working at a hotel or
something like that bar
um
um and so I think the first thing he did
was he he was like the biggest eBay
power seller and he was selling like CDs
and stuff on there he became pretty big
made a bunch of money
um and then you know was he just early
or is he really good or no the same time
as us he was smart like he was basically
kind of roll up all the smaller
Affiliates because he had better deals
with all the operators so he'd buy
someone and you know it'd be a small
affiliate and like oh I'm making like
five times and he for him it was like
this is two two years earnings or one
year he bought my site is how I knew him
my uh we have one super smart buddy who
has this like dominant position in his
game I can't say who otherwise it'll
give it away but he has the same
strategy where he's like he's like yeah
now it's unfair he goes I just go to
them and they quote me some multiple
but I have a better deal with the
payment providers or the affiliate
partner so I they think they're selling
it four times earnings but it's actually
two the moment I sign the deal they'll
go and it'll go to my payment terms and
my payment terms are just Superior and
so he's like I can just buy these all
day and I don't have to like come up
with a genius idea to even grow them
because like it's baked into just the
fact that I have more scale and
therefore I have better terms and
therefore like what they think costs X
or drives wide revenue is actually a
different variable for me
yeah for sure yeah yeah so that's
exactly why he bought my business my
poker affiliate business back then yeah
and so he was smart and that he was
rolling these up nobody was that were
other people not rolling them up back
then he sort of started that yeah I feel
like he was kind of Pioneer in our Small
industry he's just like a if you give
him a business in like an Excel sheet in
a few weeks to like look at it he's
going to come back with like here are
the three things that this could be
doing that would like 10x it and that's
really what he did for us at JM too was
I learned so much from him like I'm a
completely different business person you
know after 10 years of working with him
than I am now like what's an example
that he did at JM maybe that was a one
thing he helped me yeah one thing he
helped me a lot with was um I especially
early on I would really ride the wave of
like you know all the credit card
chargebacks hit I'm in despair on my
deathbed you know we were first hundred
thousand dollar day like I'm ready to
IPL it was just this very he used to
joke with me he's like if we were
publicly traded and you set the stock
price it would swing like a thousand
percent a day
um and one thing you really helped me
with was zooming out and thinking like
into five to ten year increments and if
you frame stuff like that nothing really
ever seems like that big of a deal
there's very few things that happen to
you or your business that are going to
materially change your trajectory over
five to ten years so like an example to
his credit before he put uh a million
into JM shortly after Kendall did his
first Angel investment
like a week before it was going to close
we had done all the documents it was
ready to go our credit card processor
throws us out and that was like half of
our Revenue which is gone and it was
like a visa thing it wasn't just them
they're like this is the underlying
Network yeah they're growing too fast
like we need a big cash Reserve we're
going to work with these guys they asked
us they're like can you send us your
financials we need a p l and a balance
sheet we didn't even know what a balance
she was right there's nothing we could
send to them so unsurprisingly they
threw us out
and I had to go back to them sort of hat
in hand to be like so uh yeah this
happened you know are we still gonna do
this or not and uh he was just like
totally understand if you uh yeah just
like we really need it but if you would
though and he's just like you know
we're gonna figure this out and he still
cut the check and we did figure it out
and there were probably 10 more of those
times along the way that he you know
just helped me think about things in
yeah the longer increments yeah because
with crypto right now like I mean people
would have said
oh impossible to sell milk grow during
this time and with a good deal you could
sell with anything with a bad deal but
it's impossible to get a good deal right
now
and I think as a general rule of thumb
that would have been true but I've
always I I hate uh anything that's like
you know this like sort of conventional
wisdom because it's like dude I'm in the
outlier business like creating a
successful startup is an outlier yeah
I'm trying to be like you know super
happy and super rich and super fit
that's an outlier like so I don't really
need any
advice that is about what the general
outcomes are instead I need advice on
how to create outlier outcomes and so
with this I was like okay well what
would have created an outlier outcome
okay crypto's going you know industry
gets shook all the big companies
they gotta freeze they can't make some
flashy acquisition right now that would
be impossible okay so I need basically
independently wealthy individuals right
that's that's the first criteria second
a lot of people are gonna say oh bad
news in crypto oh I maybe I shouldn't do
this maybe I should see how this is
gonna play out and no I need somebody
who's got long-term conviction thinks in
this five to ten year increments and uh
believes in the you know the
fundamentals and understands that
there's gonna be the UPS now then
actually during the bounds is the time
to like make Acquisitions and do things
like this like this is the time to play
offense right I feel like everyone on
Twitter there's a lot of Twitter threads
about this is the time to build yeah I
agree I'm not on Twitter I'm doing that
yeah yeah exactly the builders aren't
reading your thread
yeah so so and then that's how we ended
up finding you know basically the
perfect partner at that time
um to do this and so I feel like the uh
the outlier you know if you're gonna
play an outlier game and you're gonna
you know you have to if you want an
outlier outcome you gotta like
play Only by we only have to think in
terms of what creates that not what's
the average outcome right because the
average outcome is not the thing you
want anyways so for sure
um cool guys this was amazing uh Kendall
you didn't throw up I did it I did it
because I was really nervous before we
started yeah I was I was like uh do we
have any booze around or
yeah but you did great uh so that was
awesome uh what's your Twitter handle
which people at Kendall Seville Seville
s-a-v-i-l-l-e yep and then Mike give him
a follow how many followers you got 200
now I'm over 200.
yeah Mike Whitmire
w-i-t-t-m-e-y-e-r if you guys might get
recognized now when you walk on the
streets I doubt it a little hit of that
thing yeah actually you know what was
funny right when we had met the last
time before we did the deal
um
we were walking out of that coffee shop
and I was like all right I'll see you
later and you went to go get your Uber
and right then there was a guy who's
sitting right there the whole time he's
waiting I guess he kept looking at us
he's like hey uh Sean he's like you know
love the podcast man I'm I'm traveling
for Pittsburgh I'm just here for the day
I can't believe bumped into evolved a
lot I was like dude you should have said
that when the guy might buy the company
was it that might have helped a little
just you know a little little juice you
were joking about that after I'm like
Sean probably just paid all these apps
yeah it was a genius yeah I was like it
worked like a great job when when we
were selling our first company I did
stuff like that where I was like um I
knew that it was like is to larger
companies like the big fan companies so
it was like Corp Dev was like the who's
but who's paying attention to you at
that time and so they would follow me on
Twitter or an Instagram stuff like that
so I would just post like a ticket to
like Seattle
you know one day a trip anybody around
in the evening and it's like okay why
would he go to Seattle who's in Seattle
why would you go for a day that's got to
be a busy they're talking to them all
right come back and be like you know
when it rains it pours and it's like and
I would just post these cryptic things
because in my mind I was like I'm just
planting the seed baby I have no idea if
this did anything but uh in my head I
was like I'm really playing everybody
off of each other I thought I was like
you know yeah Catch Me If You Can type
of guy
um all right guys that was awesome yeah
we're good thank you thank you so much
and one thing is uh milk road is hiring
yeah oh yeah we're looking for like you
know those a players that have done it
before because you know we want to scale
this and uh do it as quickly as we can
and I should actually say I
um like when we were looking at this
deal we actually had a higher offer that
we turned down one of the reasons why I
told Ben I was like
I went to your Twitter feed and I saw
your tweets from back in the day that
were like crypto punks cool I think
crypto punks are cool actually and I
looked at the date I looked at what the
price was then like what would the what
were people thinking then and you were
like ahead of the curve then you had
another one this exchange that you had a
mess in rain and I was like oh dude I've
been trying to get into uh you know to
rain at that I had tried to invest at a
point in time I was like he was in there
early and I was like I feel like
if I just hang out with these guys more
I'm going to get more value out of
something completely unrelated to milk
Road just there's gonna be some random
you're gonna be like oh dude sir yeah
yeah exactly you can if I just throw me
a roadster I was like there's gonna be
something like that I'm gonna get just
out of hanging with like I'm a big
believer in that like if you find
exceptional people you don't have to
have a plan like just hang with them
find some routine or value exchange
where you're going to be in each other's
orbit all the time because something
good is going to come out of that and so
similarly if somebody wants to work at
the milk Road I would say like
cool it's gonna have good pay it's a
cool project people really love the
product that's that's all true
but also like the same reason I wanted
to to sell and work with you guys is the
same reason really anybody should want
to do that like if you heard the stories
on this podcast you're probably like God
these guys are awesome like they they
went through a bunch of [__] but they
figure stuff out and they play their own
game those are the type of people who
you want to like work with even if
you're like someday I want to be more
entrepreneurial than I am today
you want to get a job where you're kind
of in direct proximity with people who
are very much like that because it'll
change the way your own brain works for
sure you want to get in shape hang out
with fit people yeah for sure yeah yeah
when we what was the body fat challenge
did you win
last time we hung out he was at like day
that's how we're gonna finish the pause
yeah I gotta know
um so what was the challenge you were at
the end of a challenge yeah I'm in a
group called entrepreneurs organization
I'm in a forum with seven other uh
Dallas entrepreneurs we meet monthly we
do a retreat once a year and in advance
of the retreat everybody sets themselves
a fitness goal and everybody puts in
like 500 bucks that if you hate your
goal you get your money back if you
don't it goes towards funding my retreat
so no win just a it's not loose yeah
just to not lose and avoid the shame
um so maybe three months out everybody
sets their goals and I thought I was
like 15 body fat at that time so I was
like I'm gonna get to 10. I've never
done that before I'm gonna go for it
let's do it so I you know slam it down
on the table I'm like boys I'm doing it
and then uh I start working really hard
the next two months and a month out I'm
like I'm gonna go get a dexa to see like
I think I'm probably 11 somewhere in
there like I gotta be really I'm almost
there I'm almost there and I had like
weaned out in the mirror materially and
I go and get the decks when I was 15-7.
said I was nowhere near where I thought
I was and then I really like killed
myself that next month and I ended up
getting down to like 12 more so 12 one
okay but lucky for me some of the guys
didn't schedule dexes so the body fat
guys were like we're gonna consider it
acceptable to use those scale things and
on the scale I was like eight something
so I got my 500 back okay wow yeah the
good guys the reality is I did not I did
my goal yeah yeah you were like really
hardcore about it that's right if you
were like not eating any of the carbs it
was just like really sad you were just
kind of in the corner yeah it was
definitely sad oh man like the chef just
made this really cool thing and I can't
eat anything of it all right does Mike
really do this 500 yeah it's like no
Mike needs to not lose Mike does not
like to lose at anything and he said
himself a stupid goal that he has to hit
now next year though I'm gonna get it
yeah what I would have done is I would
have been like what am I now and just
like doing done like one percent under
that just like make sure I win yeah Mike
wants to make his life hard and go
uphill no last year I I was I probably
weighed like 175 pounds or once 80 or
something like that and everyone at the
table did like a weight loss thing so I
just thought that's what these were it
was like one of the I think it was the
first year we did it and so I was like
well I want to get down to you know 175.
they're like well what are you now I'm
like 178.
it was 40 pounds
in my fault you guys have been slacked
yeah you need to write a book called
going uphill I feel like that's gonna be
your your book yeah it'll be the bias
you know when you're done working then
you can start tweeting you're you're
uphill about your uphill book I actually
have one last uphill story away yeah so
and Whitefish this year I mentioned we
were doing uh I was doing this in the
resort and they would open it like an
hour before the whiffs ran so only the
people going uphill I guess just because
it's safer there's not a ton of people
coming down so there was one morning it
was like negative 10 wind chill they
actually never even opened the resort
that day it was too windy it was just
miserable out so I was like all right
this is perfect optimal conditions so I
suit up you rang
they suit up and get out there and uh I
had just gotten like I'd never done this
in a resort and I really had only done
this maybe five times with my buddy who
always was like the sherpa he was like
you know help me figure stuff out
whatever so there's this route you have
to take up the hill
and
I was the first one going it was like 6
a.m and I'm just I'm going straight up
that path I'm like marching doing well
feeling good and then there's this one
section because I've done it a few times
so I knew there was this one section
that was pretty steep and there were a
few times going up that the Skins would
like start to slip a little bit and I
was getting really scared because I
don't ski so like if this thing turns
around I'm like I can't do anything
and so I'm going straight up this thing
like marching the winds blasting me the
Isis blasphemy and I I'm one step away
from the top and I take the step and it
slips and the whole thing just falls
apart I'm falling backwards downhill
doing the somersault thing like this
skis go flying off that whole thing
set them at the bottom and I am very
humbled now because there's like 20 I
realize there's like 20 people behind me
who just watched that and I'm gathering
all my stuff like they're helping me out
and I look up the hill because they're
starting to go and all of them are
zigzagging back and forth so it's not as
Steep and I was going straight line
directly up the hill I'm like oh that's
why they're not far
[Laughter]
wouldn't have it any other way yeah
there you go metaphor of Life awesome
well thanks guys for doing this I I know
a little out of your comfort zone but
I'm glad you guys did it thanks for
having us appreciate it cool all right
[Music]
foreign